stefan is a great character
he's uh a gay guy who's kind of in the
nightclub scene
one of the things that i love about that
character is you crack yourself up right
isn't that the cardinal rule of saturday
night live you're not allowed to laugh
at your own sketch yeah no 100
right
so how does that happen i'm bad at my
job especially no no because i love that
stuff like you put your hands on your
face over your face you're stopping
yourself from laughing at your own lines
now what i read was that the reason you
laugh at your own lines when you do that
character the guy who writes that
character with you john mulaney yeah
he'll sometimes switch the lines he'll
put stuff up without telling me uh or
he'll tell me as i walk out anything to
kind of shake me up because i get very
nervous i never my whole time at snl
really i'm incred i have real bad
anxiety and so i get very very nervous
before i go out i don't blame you it's
yeah it's live it's live television i'm
someone that goes over my lines kind of
obsessively
uh i run them run them constantly do you
not work off the cue cards i do go off
the cue cards but i like to know what's
coming up kind of obsessively so
uh if something goes wrong or i kind of
know what's happening i can i can kind
of relax out there right and john knows
this so john
thank you john so when you're doing
stefan the cue card comes up and you've
never seen it before that happens
sometimes or he will say hey i change as
i'm walking out there he'll go he'll
whisper you know hey i changed the
nightclub lady to gay leota
and
so when it comes up i know it's coming
up i'll start laughing the one that he
really got me on that i did not know was
up there was uh
the uh and halloween it said um
so they're flipping the cue cards and
then i'm expecting one joke and it comes
over and it's in new you know fresh
writing on the cue card and it says hey
seth do you know how there's uh
you know blacula's the black dracula and
he goes yes i go well they made a jewish
one you know what jewish dracula's
called
and he said what and they turned the cue
card over and it says sydney applebaum
that's so [ __ ] great
so you've never seen that line no and i
completely it stopped the show for like
a minute i was done i was done and on
the other side of the cue cards i see
you know john and the other right
everyone's dying laughing because
they're just waiting for it it's so
great and i was like oh
sydney applebaum
and it was hard to recover from that
totally and i'm just going like
oh no you know and now i'm laughing
through the whole thing
and the californians fred armisen's
constantly trying to make me break fred
fred just didn't escape well fred just
did a sketch recently called short-term
memory theater which was i was a doctor
saying i've worked with these actors
these people have short-term memory loss
right i'm gonna help them we're gonna do
a play they they remember every single
line you'll see they will remember every
single line
and then the joke is out of the gate
they're just looking at me and i'm under
my breath going i'm telling them their
lines because they don't know
so fred on air without telling me he
came out in this big giant jacket
big puffy jacket and then forever just
didn't know where to put it and you see
me go give me the jacket come on like
give me a check and there's no acting in
it like
there's like a there's like a 30 second
span where it's nothing that's on the
cue card it's just me and fred
interacting with each other he goes is
the play over and i'm like no the play's
not over what's that
and we start breaking we start laughing
do you run the risk of being too inside
when you start doing stuff yeah you know
what you're doing is you're getting
you're getting comfortable with your
friends and you're getting comfortable
right and so after that sketch
i went to lauren and said hey you know
i'm breaking a lot now we're kind of
this is is this getting ridiculous you
know i'm sorry because i i legitimately
feel awful after that happens if you saw
me after every stephan i'm going like
[ __ ] oh you know i get very mad i'm like
and he said well if what you're saying
is not funny if like what the words
actually you know what i mean right then
i i would get mad but what you're saying
is especially stefan it's ridiculously
funny so don't worry don't worry about
it so much and you guys are having a
good time out there and i don't know i
wouldn't be able to keep a straight face
with fred coming in with the jacket and
everything you know yeah it seems
genuine